[Music]
you see the all right so today we are
going to talk about money I was inspired
by Stephane Graham because he was
talking about his multiple income
sources but because I'm an idiot or a
baller
you know tomato tomahto I feel like it's
more fitting that I show you guys my
reckless spending so as you know I got
forty five thousand dollars in bonus
with my new software engineering job so
what I did was that I took 19 thousand
dollars of it and put it into my 401k so
that the company dude I'm kidding man
dude I'm not a loser
I don't do 401ks also you didn't click
this video for this you clicked it for
my reckless spending so I'm gonna show
you so as you can see if I do smiting
over time oh it's pretty much a hockey
stick I mean usually people would be
pretty happy about hockey stick graph
but I mean this is my spending so I
don't think that's a great thing so as
you can see according to this my last
month spending was eighteen thousand and
nine hundred dollars and well I mean you
know I mean we should dig deeper into it
because it's not always accurate because
sometimes the program they they look at
transfers and they think that suspending
but it's actually not or I actually
spend more and it just wasn't recorded
on this program so we're gonna try to
export all of that into an Excel
spreadsheet and then I'll dive deep into
it alright before we continue this video
I just want to say that viewers
discretion is advice I made this video
for entertainment purposes please do not
spend all your money recklessly like me
and you have to know that my net worth
is totally fine it has been growing
faster than ever
so please
spen responsibly do not do like me it's
only for entertainment and if you're
wondering how's my net worth still
growing so fast despite me spending so
much well I'm not gonna tell you is it
because I'm a trust fund baby I don't
know is it because of my bitcoins I
don't know
enjoy the video alright so I'm having
I'm having problems with the autofocus
so I'm gonna have to put this in the
background so in case you were wondering
why I have a bitmoji this is what I use
it for alright okay there we go
alright so now what we're gonna do is
I'm going to rename the description just
for ones privacy reasons and also too so
that I actually remember what it is
because now sometimes the names are
quite cryptic it doesn't mean anything
so I'm gonna do that first and then
secondly what I'm gonna do I'm going to
separate them into buckets of spendings
because I don't like the preset
spendings that they use so I'm gonna
bucket them in to birthday gift business
expense
charity entertainment food I don't
effing know materialistic desires
medical other rent self-improvement
transportation and travel before you ask
me what they are I'm gonna go through
them okay so don't worry about it
and I don't effing know it's just
because I didn't want to sort them
anymore there were a lot of small
purchases from Amazon and I didn't I
don't have time I don't have time to
search through all of them okay alright
so I got it I did a lot of data cleaning
cuz you know I'm a I'm a data scientist
so I ordered it by the amount spent so
you could see it in order of amount
spent alright so let's go to the summary
now I made a pivot table and then you
know a graph because why not honestly
it's not even necessary but if you look
at the breakdown then the biggest
expense is this line here which is
materialistic desires which is
everything that's related shopping and
stuff that
need so that is the highest spending
with 4000 dollars and then the next
highest is entertainment that is like
concerts what else
it's like concerts comedy shows stuff
like that and then here it's like
business expense
this is relate to like cameras anything
that I need to run my youtube channel
well I mean I actually don't need it
it's more okay fine
some of it can go to materialistic
spending but it's related to YouTube so
I'll put in business expense and then we
have food which is a thousand dollars
which includes you know restaurants
actually it only includes restaurants I
mean I never do groceries so it's it's
mainly restaurants and then we got rent
which is my rent I mean I don't pay
4,600 I don't know if you saw my other
video and I said I paid 4,600 chill man
I have roommates it was only clickbait
okay I only pay 1,900 and then we have
self-improvement which is the smallest
bucket of my spending for
self-improvement I have a personal
training and maybe audible or something
like that but yeah as you can see I'll
spend a lot on that I don't do a lot of
self-improvement and then transportation
which is like uber and so one thousand
dollars
dude I might as well rent a Tesla or
something
[ __ ] so here it says 22,000 I'm not sure
if that's true maybe like I'm going to
like clean it up a little bit okay
so let's look at it deep dive style so
monthly rent $1,900
okay the Apple watch atomies 1400 k con
la tickets I bought three of them so
this shouldn't really be 1300 I should
divide this by three so let's see this
divided by 3 so then $1,000 for my new
bed sheets bedding do that and all that
totally worth it because now when I
sleep naked it feels like you know so
silky hands are all over my body
it feels really good and then here is
Hamilton ticket I bought a Hamilton
ticket for my brother his fiancee and me
and yeah it's on me so this one I have
to leave it there because even though I
bought three of them they're not paying
me back all right and then next we have
ax owed this is Trevor Noah
yeah so for Trevor Noah I bought two
tickets that was yeah that was for me
and another friend and that cost 964
I can't divide that by two because
they're not paying me back okay and then
I bought a pic so 3xl it's right here
why did I buy it no idea I think it's
like it's a hedge you know in case one
day Android becomes better than iPhone
or that one day iPhones are not cool
anymore so at least the transition will
be a lot easier for me because I now I
use both so it's a lot easier for me to
transition into Android when the time
comes
and then the next spending three of them
six hundred and forty dollars that is my
flight ticket to Japan because I am
going to Japan this year I bought them
for my friends but they will pay me back
so I will delete these two okay oh wait
oh [ __ ] I want to say the joke I wanted
to say oh yeah and the reason why I
bought three tickets to Japan is because
I want both of the seat next to me to be
empty so I bought all three of them but
no I'm not that rich and then all right
$633 this is a business expense it's
it's it's kind of like a box it's for
doing live videos using my camera I use
it for my tech interview probe might as
well plug tech interview pro now good
news we added new videos about system
design and also about how to transition
into software engineering and then the
reason why I bought this live video
thing is that we do live videos every
two weeks for the Facebook group and
then you can ask us q and A's and stuff
like that if you're interested click on
tech interview procom all right and then
next we got Ticket Master what is this
it's five hundred forty-four bucks what
did i buy I don't remember
[ __ ] the [ __ ] that I by July 4th oh god
I got it ok ok ok ok ok
got it oh yeah so I bought tickets for
Ali Wong front seat ok actually not
friend see the the road before the front
seat because I don't want to get I don't
want them to talk to me while they do
their show because I always get nervous
so next we have wow that's a lot we have
for Facebook charges two of them is for
advertising I mean you know how do you
expect my channel to grow you really
think that I make good content which is
how I grow my channel don't be so naive
I pay for my subscribers and then the
other two is for Mental Health America
which is a charity I'm doing a
fundraiser and I put in five hundred
dollars it's not a thousand so this is
wrong
because I kind of did it twice by
accident so it's only five hundred
dollars I'll talk about that later I
don't wanna I don't want you guys to
think I'm a good person or anything
alright and then oh four hundred forty
dollars that is my virtual assistant I
pay for a virtual assistants so that
they can manage my calendar they can
respond to some emails they can help me
do some invoicing and stuff like that
very useful highly recommend it if
you're rich and then the next one Taman
that's actually just a guitar so I
bought a guitar you can see it right
here
yeah ticka ticka do
let's see and then I got a lot of
business expense here is a pure bird
press van no what the [ __ ] did I buy
WordPress I don't know okay so some of
it is pretty dumb okay I guess you got
the gist of it you got the bulk of my
spending and let's go back to the pivot
table and see how it looks it's not that
bad it's it's it's it's still $19,000
okay mmm crazy thing honestly I am okay
with everything but what the hell
transportation is so high let me look at
that so clearly I like uber more but
holy [ __ ] $1000
is that right dude I spent $1,000 in a
month
horse [ __ ] did I might as well just pay
for a Tesla or something oh you know
what you live and learn
alright anyways I'm gonna wrap this
video in terms of money-wise so as you
can see travel $900 it's not that bad
actually
transportation $1,000 I could do better
in that self-improvement I shouldn't
worry about spending more in
self-improvement but clearly I don't
care about my self-improvement that much
rent 1900 I can't change anything those
are some utility costs whatever other I
don't want to go into that but wait what
is another let me go check cash advance
intra don't know what that is virtual
assistant was another all made cleaning
service I also put that other that's I
recommend that too especially if you're
lazy right so okay that's it's not that
bad I'm not gonna change anything
they're entertainment I don't want to I
don't want to change that because
entertainment is important right let's
go back into entertainment I want to see
what I pay for entertainment yeah like
like totally worth it right Spotify I
have to Showtime gotta Hamilton tickets
you know it's for my brother it's
important
Vanda go movie totally important I don't
know what in-flight Wi-Fi that's
important too
patreon on the white says Jim but
patreon I got to support the patreon
members Tiffany young tickets kpop
really important
we're gonna skip this one we're gonna
skip that one Nintendo Digital I could
take that off it's only four dollars
Trevor Noah thought that was worth it I
was really new on that I mean what are
you gonna do for your money if you're
not gonna have fun with it
Cate con la tickets totally worth it Ali
Wong totally worth it so yeah I'm not
gonna change anything in my
entertainment business expense
dude it's business expense manse you
know to recap yes I spent a lot this
month but that's probably not every
month I hope and there's two reasons why
I spend so much the first reason is
consumption smoothing all right it's an
econ term learn it every time every time
I spend too much that's my excuse I'm
just doing consumption smoothing and
then the second reason is I don't plan
on saving for retirement because I'm
banking on the fact that one of my
investments will pan out and will make
me rich so that saving a few thousands
here and there would be irrelevant Oh
what kind of investments dogs real
estate bitcoins no you plebs okay I'm
investing in my future kids I'm banking
on the fact that one of them will be
extremely rich and that will pay
dividends to me it didn't work out for
my parents but I'm optimistic for my
kids I should really call my parents ooh
a new kpop video anyways now I want to
talk about the charity section so I got
all these corgis from A Thousand skies
so thank you so much but I don't know
what to do with them I'm not gonna keep
them in my place forever so I decided to
give them out in exchange for a donation
to my fundraiser in Mental Health
America so that's when I decided to
donate five hundred to bootstrap my
fundraiser so that it doesn't look like
a total failure if I don't have anyone
donating so if you're in the Bay Area SF
Bay Area you could you know for a small
donation even just two bucks you can
just give two bucks and then I could
personally hand you the Corgi and I
could meet you and I could give you a
corgi but if you're not in the SFO
area unfortunately I can't deliver it to
you but if you really want when you
could go on thousand skies calm in case
you want to know they're not paying me
for this I just really really like the
corgis because there's a sentimental
value to it if you watch my videos from
the beginning you would understand why
it's because many times I interacted
with the Corgi on one of my videos that
went really really popular and I kind of
associate my success to these corgis and
yeah and I kind of want to pay homage to
it anyways that's it for now the video
is long enough unless I edit it really
well I'm not sure but thanks for
watching really appreciate it and I'll
leave some links down below like for
example the fundraiser link and a
thousand sky's link and yeah I hope you
enjoy it so I'll leave you with this
don't spend recklessly spend responsibly
but remember self-worth before network
yeah
[Music]